une voix en leur faveur celle de la
république dominicaine
sur la totalité des membres du conseil
de sécurité c'est le seul soutien que
les états unis ont réussi à obtenir pour
voter leur résolution
tous les alliés européens de washington
se sont abstenus une véritable
démonstration de désaccord avec la
stratégie iranienne de donald trump
mais le président américain furieux ne
compte pas en rester là
oui nous nous savions ce qu'allait être
l'issue du vote mais nous allons faire
un snack bac
vous verrez ça la semaine prochaine oui
vous verrez ça la semaine prochaine le
président poutine veut organiser un
sommet en vidéoconférence y participerez
vous probablement pas non je pense que
nous voulons attendre après les
élections
écoutez l'iran veut tellement que je
perde vous savez que l'iran c'est une
toute autre histoire en ce moment snap
bac est une forme de droit de veto
employés à l'envers mais pour en
bénéficier
les etats unis doivent faire reconnaître
leur statut de pays participants au
texte sur le nucléaire iranien
un accord dont ils se sont retirés en
2018 en cas de succès concernant cette
manoeuvre
washington pourrait imposer le
rétablissement des sanctions de l'onu
contre téhéran
en attendant l'iran savoure cette gifle
diplomatique infligé aux américains
à mon avis cette journée restera dans
l'histoire de notre iran et dans
l'histoire de la lutte contre
l'arrogance mondiale
regardez à quel point les états unis
sont humiliés le pouvoir de l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien qui a
été endommagée par les crimes des états
unis et d'israël et qui restent à moitié
vivant a vaincu les états unis
de son côté le premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou a dénoncé
une décision scandaleuse
si les états unis décident d'enclencher
le snap bac un long contentieux pourrait
alors être déclenchée et au final venir
affaiblir le rôle même des nations unies
en tant qu'institution derrière cette
manoeuvre américaine certains voient la
volonté de donald trump de rendre
impossible un éventuel retour des
américains dans cet accord au cas où il
ne serait pas réélu en novembre prochain